hey guys i'm ryan right so matt's for yo
he did a video called how to react which
pretty much ripped apart reactors most
reactors now he's done a new video
called how to actually react for me he
did a ten-minute version because I got a
copyright strike so I can't upload
videos longer than 15 minutes now
apparently damn Deadpool leak test
footage you can catch the full 20 minute
length one but right now let's watch the
salmon and one together hi I'm not for
you there is so much to be going on
about the reactor community a lot of
people looking from the outside in are
saying that reactors are basically
substance view mongers exploding and
famed earning money off of
effortlessness a lot of reactors melting
from the OSI out are arguing that their
individual content is differed from the
stereotypical mold which was created by
the more popular reactions and they're
pleading for critics to not make
overgeneralization we've recently seen
PewDiePie and directly take the first
approach I know I was about him not
understanding the community I'm going to
analyze this spectacle from a different
perspective no jokes a reaction to the
reacting community I suppose his jinx
personally I'm friendly with ryan right
of the real rejects hey guys who has
actually been extremely welcoming to
someone like me who doesn't have much
traction as a youtuber so you can see
that I understand that these reactors
are real people some create better
content than others but I'm here to
analyze what reacting foundationally is
and how it has changed some of the basis
of the YouTube platform at first there's
more of a hop on the bandwagon
get-rich-quick scheme but I feel like
some reactors have almost started to
feel guilty and started providing other
alternative content for their audience
that they are massively I don't care
about the yard work equals prosperity
right there are three groups that I'm
going to break this community down into
people cannot assume things based on
popular opinion research must be done
and analysis must be performed before
you can make any type of assumption for
the sake of visual representation of a
call the group's low middle and high
okay the lower group consists of
youtubers who make reaction videos that
consists of the following videos that
are only about 30 seconds or less longer
than the actual video they were reacting
putting more time promoting their
channel than they do actually reacting
when reactions master and staring in a
video and offer no other input either
during or
and feeding off of the hard work of
content creators do reactors work hard
to earn their fair share in a way yes it
takes time to film it takes time to edit
it takes time to upload be in a stronger
way no now they shoulda lean reactors
have mostly done for them in the video
that they're watching are you going to
argue that reactions are not view
grabbers you react to what is popular
and therefore you are popular with
little to no effort I don't see anyone
reacting to the rap battle that I just
made because it's not popular by
reacting to content what you are also
doing interest taking views away from
the content creators is it possible that
you direct traffic to a source by
watching their video yeah possible do
you physically take years away from the
content creators no views are only a
surplus they cannot be reduced what it
is doing is expanding the viewership
which is foundationally good but in a
way that lead to the source without
seeing the actual response I am certain
that reactors will argue that reactions
are free advertising but that's only
half true in the event that your
audience is seeing the video that you
are reacting to for the first time this
is how it really works advertising
serves the purpose of drawing traffic
towards a source that earns revenue
right you are not advertising if your
audience gets to watch the entire video
your reaction who needs to locate and
watch the original video when they can
watch the entire thing in your reaction
i'm going to give you hardcore evidence
right now when I made my parody video
how to react the real rejects got over
31,000 views on their reaction to it
currently today the video that they
reacted to that I made has 1,600 views
video trafficking only roughly 180 six
of those views directly to me with an
average view time of 46 seconds their
reaction has over 19 times the amount of
view is that my original content has the
original content the factor that allows
the reaction to exist has less views
than the reaction basically reactions
are dependent entity that is frowned
upon because the majority of the work
comes from the video they're reacting to
and not the reaction a good example of
how reacting does equal advertising is
when people basically react to something
that is an advertisement for something
else when the real rejects react to
movie trailers they promote the movie
but why does it work here because the
trailer is an issue see which is freely
planted through word of mouth to promote
the actual source of income going to see
the movie what I found to be
in regards to reminisce sizing is to
make a partnership with YouTube and the
people whose videos you react to I know
this sounds like you so much work calm
down do you realize that reacting is the
welfare of the YouTube community you are
sewing yourself watching someone else's
hard work offering sometimes saltless
responses doing watching some of your
reactions it is so forced people are
literally like it or jump it up and down
and blankly smile or know their
interests and your fingers and stuff
just to have a nice used to provide what
the title says every action who wants to
watch someone stare at a video for three
minutes and then offer nothing
afterwards so why not just jump up and
down and pretend to have a reaction well
all content become dumbs down to a point
where it's mindless views earning
mindless revenue with no creativity I
think that reactor should only show
parts of the videos that they react to
the event that the video commercial
reaction food no reaction just staring I
will propose your argument back to me
now Mateo part of reacting is not having
a reaction it lets the audience know
that they didn't like or were
indifferent to that part of the video
you can tell your audience what parts of
the video that you did and didn't like
in the part of the video that should be
the largest part your reaction and
analysis if reactors can find a certain
way to only show parts of the video that
the title says that it will their
reactions the audience is more engaged
and doesn't feel bored left skipping
through the video to find the parts that
they came therefore there is no hard
work involved in a one-take staring come
that's more editing and most importantly
the advertising aspect becomes real if
the audience doesn't get to see the
whole video you can tell them where to
find the whole video in the description
or in an annotation but if you give that
incentive to go to the original content
you become a very important segue they
go directly to you and then instead of
having the connection end there make it
so that you can be the middle link to
allowing all of these people to grow
their audiences I'm a huge power girl
he'll use it well please thank you let's
move on to the middle group reactors who
engage with their audience have certain
size jokes with them and recurring
themes our own Magnus can be an example
interjections of editing side
information like Tyrone Magnus doing
aerobics with a lightsaber they spend
time at the end of their video to
discuss their thoughts in length offer a
wide variety of personalities for each
different reaction that
do you can make up all these
personalities on your own or you could
be like the real rejects who have all
these different personalities that they
call upon for different types of
reaction videos if you have no other
content as a reactor that much we know
what your mission is if you're not
offering extended thoughts reviews and
analysis it's cliffie why not watch a
video and to get to see someone else's
reaction to it at the same time viewers
may be interested in getting two for one
instead of being directed to the actual
source of the content reactors are
getting similar amounts of fame
regardless that how hard they work
people who make reaction videos as a
sort of alternative content for an
already diverse channel are not reactors
they are content creators in the higher
group we have two things content
creators are working script writers
editors music Cruiser sound designers
videographer set designers budget
handlers or someone who's a combination
of them all let's look at this in terms
of money equals views again people
always say the rich should give their
fair share in the event that the poor
are poor and choose to stay poor because
of the benefits that they get from being
poor and the rich are rich because they
have worked to climb and economic ladder
over time what would you consider a fair
share is it fair for hard work to feed
no work so as your new dictator of the
reacting community here are all the
rules that none of you will follow one
make reacting about your reactions not
the videos that you're reacting to two
like faces and thought spaces are dead
air get rid of them three everybody
wants a fair share right give some
incentive for views back to their proper
owners for promote those who you react
to don't forget that you were reacting
to something something that someone made
something that you are using in your
title for you to get views help them get
some in return five preserve the dream
of hard work equals success why should
anyone work hard anymore when something
like this exists where you don't have to
work hard make your videos to break the
mould you have created the mold now get
out of it six actually react if your
insight develop a mind frame that is
specific to your persona when people
watch them in other video make them a
thing huh I wonder how Ryan Wright would
react to this he's a big softie for
stuff like this let's hear what he has
to say so you can go to his channel give
insight be a thinker in your own right
become someone that people can look up
to not look at i'm at four yo proudly
announce that i'm learning to be your
ruler of the reactor munity 2015
sponsored by no one voted for by no one
oh wait by the way i have a quick song
that I made
in regards to how I feel I give you your
proper respect so please take it as
something that you can appreciate I
think reacting is causing both good and
harm accumulator my ultimate thoughts
into the song and if you'll like it move
along but I think I'm in a position to
say what I want and want the truth
original content still has a lot of
views but two sides of the other routes
know like the hypotenuse foundation is
present and you draw from both ends of
it somehow your longevity is evidently
this resident display relevance there's
one thing see don't share with a MP and
mr. platform of which departed if you
claim to be and you don't see the
struggle that had made me want to call
it quits to trying to find a strong
snitch from which I build an audio
reacting the only thing is lagging as a
silver platter open center is in 10
years lose it matter who are entering a
10 you're that not many can endow say no
home you're setting up a tent and in the
end you are not a 10-year career success
story but could you be in cash to rot
without real bay and you really in a
will to be done and the honest and most
of your archives had promised that
there's one thing a and B both have in
common and its content if you have that
in common to this multiplied to move a
plane to do was everything I try to do i
guess the slightest view you've
manipulated a system with raw to look
and nothing numbers i can do nothing but
applaud you and take it as a compliment
is taken as acceptance that success
requires a certain gimmick that aren't
you proud to mess so it's left to say is
well fair i still think that its welfare
so you'll find the elsewhere
don't cool rap man that for you check
out my original content I really want a
lot of hard work into it I think that
you appreciate it that's all for now
subscribe for something see you guys
later Mat for yo all right guys well
that was a 10 minute version you guys
can go to his channel matt for yo and
check out the 20 minute cut like i said
it in the previous video i did for him
this channel the main driving source is
the reaction review show but there are
other things on this for example i just
posted a short film that I did with
Sally there are movie reviews spoiler
reviews movie news I feel this channel
does do a lot more than just reactions
and even when we do the reactions we do
tend to give further analysis like this
reacting thing is a weird world because
there's a lot of people doing reactions
now it's fun I can see why a lot of
people like doing it i remember when i
started doing it I was like if I'm not
given worthwhile opinions and this is
stupid I think anyone could do what I do
with the reaction part you just be
yourself and watch a [ __ ] video it's
not hard i know that actually giving
further opinions that's part of a
reaction to me because the reaction
alone can't say everything that you're
actually thinking and feeling there's
only so much that your face can tell and
is interesting how he was pointing out
that reactions can be a necessity that
they can be a promotional service there
are videos for example Matt for Rios
video and there are other videos that my
reaction to it has gotten more views
than the actual video itself but like he
said that acts as a driving source to
them like I know this video is going to
get more views than the actual video but
Matt foreo I want people to check him
out I want people to go to this guy I've
talked to him a few times he's very
intellectual he's creative he offers
original content the dude can rap I mean
he just proved that with a fun song but
he can really wrap the part I don't
fully agree with I know there are people
who skip around reactions is good
looking for the most interesting part of
the reaction this child's over 200,000
subs and most people want a full
reaction even if I just have a blank
face at that time because that's just
what I'm feeling people still want that
part of the video because it's those
moments where the reaction does generate
that make it work
while because for me if it's just cut to
reaction reaction reaction reaction it
would be a montage it wouldn't be as
entertaining or as fun or as rewarding
when the reactions actually there it's a
good like build up to it it's a good
payoff to it it's just honest you know
like if every video I watched and I was
freaking out i clearly be lying i
clearly be forcing it and i don't like
to do that i don't like to force any
[ __ ] when i'm doing this you know i
like to have fun but I don't want to
miss the actual video and I don't want
to lie about anything of my reaction
like I noticed a lot of people are doing
just simple reaction videos because
people like watching people react I get
it but I don't watch a lot of reaction
channels because AI don't want to mimic
anyone be I feel a lot of them are not
that interesting unless you're getting
something like Star Wars or Batman vs
Superman where you know there's going to
be a reaction that's worth it but if
it's a smaller video or a video that's
not as viral you know you're not
entirely sure you're gonna get a big
reaction like this video alone I got a
lot from it but you didn't you know
obviously didn't see me like feeling a
whole time I was cracking jokes every
once awhile but you don't see me like
actually feeling so much and really
reacting to it another reason why I
don't want to cut around is because I
know that some people will only watch it
if it's during someone's reactions so I
want them to catch the whole video I do
put a link in the description box
there's a link in the description box
format for use video so you can actually
check it out a full screen up to be
watching my face looking at it but yeah
there's few reaction channels I do like
your shirt i row Magnus less Tyrone we
all know you got a big dick come on
Tyrone I'll put it in my mouth oh I
can't only get the head of your huge
[ __ ] in my mouth anyway yeah i mean like
i said i got strike so i gotta keep this
video short so gonna end it here if you
guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine and periscope because if we get
more followers we can get even more
product placement for things such ads
xbox 360 games xbox 360 is a great
system that is so much fun xbox if
you're watching this I will do Let's
Plays if you send me free video games I
mean come
the channel has over 200,000 subs that's
right I help me you got some money you
know I could play the video game for you
guys you can play a little bit of halo 5
get a little bit of a reaction going
while I do a let's play whoa holy [ __ ]
that was crazy haha I'm teabagging make
you guys more money by giving me free
video games